let's start with some breaking news HSBC
is on the brink of a deal to rescue the
UK arm of Silicon Valley Bank after a
large Stitch agreement that will avert
the technology focused lenders in
solvency well Sky presenter Ian King is
here now with the latest Ian this has
come very very much just before the
markets open really just tell us a
little bit more Willie can join in the
last few moments the bank of England has
put out a statement confirming that HSBC
UK has indeed bought Silicon Valley
Banks UK business I can read you the
statement says the bank of England in
consultation with the Prudential
regulation Authority hm Treasury and the
financial conduct Authority has taken
the decision to sell Silicon Valley Bank
UK limited the UK subsidiary of the U.S
Bank's HSBC UK bank hsbc's authorized
and supervised by the pra and the FCA
this action has been taken to stabilize
svb UK ensuring the continuity of
banking services minimizing disruption
to the UK technology sector and
supporting confidence in the financial
system the bank of England says the bank
and hm treasury can confirm that all
depositors money with svb UK is safe and
secure as a result of this transaction
svb UK's business will continue to be
operated normally by svb UK all services
will continue to operate as normal and
customers should not notice any changes
and the bank goes on to say customers
can continue to contact svb UK through
the usual channels and borrowers should
make any loan repayments to svb UK as
normal svb UK staff remain employed by
svb UK and svb UK continues to be a pra
FCA authorized bank and then the final
line of this statement from the bank of
England says today's announcement
supersedes the bank's 10th of March
statement that absent any meaningful
further information it intended to apply
to the court to place svb UK into an
insolvency procedure so that is the
breaking news in the last couple of
moments the bank of England confirmed
firming there that Silicon Valley Bank
UK has been bought by HSBC UK all
depositors uh save deposits are safe and
secure the business will continue to
trade as normally that of course
confirmation of a story that our
colleague Mark Lyman broke just a few
moments uh before seven o'clock there I
think this will reassure a lot of
people's Silicon Valley Bank UK has some
3 300 UK customers all of whom more or
less are in the tech and startup sector
there was a lot of concern over the
weekend about the ability of those
customers to access their cash there was
something like seven billion pounds
worth of their money held on deposit
with svb UK those deposits are now safe
that breaking news in the last two
minutes HSBC UK has bought Silicon
Valley Bank UK